[Music]
event is this always had a key
need something more your brother is
about to declare war we must stop him
sounds like fun
let's do it I'm nobody but I can't save
my home and the people that I love
mr. C Aquaman rated pg-13 experience at
an IMAX December 21st
[Music]
my parents were from different worlds
and that was a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day
a son of the land and a son of the Seas
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the bridge between land and sea
rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now well what's the
way buying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far
inland check this place huh
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert let's say you do
your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all right now hold still
hey what are you doing we need water
you're the closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you suited my power journey beyond
the edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it would bring destruction
but in terms of the Trulia
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what did you say something
something tried it the Beast has
awakened the time has come
for lantus to rise again
who the hell are you
[Music]
oh is awesome
the war is coming to the surface
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
not King
[Music]
clintus who's always had a king now I
need something more
but what could be greater than akin
[Music]
a hero
[Music]